um anyone here watch shark tank yeah
yeah okay who's your favorite
shark tank
shark member who's your favorite shark
thank you for that yeah mark cuban kevin
o'leary
he didn't say name the sharks
he said what's your favorite shark
disguise
two of them all right all right fine
how about you mark cuban is my favorite
shark you know what
i would say cuban too
but now after this guest speaker i got a
i got a new favorite you got a soft spot
i got a suspect because this guy crushed
it i'm talking about the people shark
damon john
he was the guest speaker he opened up
this conference
you know he's founded fubu hip-hop
fashion clothing now he's a
multi-multi-multi-millionaire
on shark tank damon jump so he spoke at
this thing let me tell you something
about the image dude can tell some
stories dudes got some flow he's got
inspiration he's got comedy he's got
humor he's got some some you know
tugging on the heart strings the guy
brought a dj
guy about a freaking dj the [ __ ]
thicket mix it up while he's talking his
[ __ ] was on point it was it was just
actually a really
good
speech and presentation you bring a dj
to your speech yeah you ain't playing
around okay
so he came correct and more than
anything you know we talk about
confidence is key when you're giving a
speech you know about this with stand-up
comedy relatability relate to the
audience audience interaction crowd
participation
dude had it going on i'll give him that
and um
he actually told a funny story about
how when he was you know you know what
fubu stands for you know that's his
company right fubu yeah do you know what
it stands for no no no none of you zero
okay so he grew up in new york uh he was
in hip-hop he was in fashion he was
trying to make his way into the hip-hop
predominantly a black audience obviously
so fubu
stands for
for us
by us
that was his thing but did you know that
before fubu it was bufu
okay
by us for us
okay and he told he told this funny joke
that
the girls
the girl he was dating at the time
her brother was gay
and he would always be very
uh you know
gay
as gay people are yeah whatever
and he was basically saying uh
what's his buffoo stuff
and he's oh that's my brand bios for us
he goes well in the gay community yeah
bufo stands for something else you can
do the math on what b you
[ __ ] i knew this was gonna get sexual
okay it's not sexual at all well yeah
obviously when i brought the gay thing
but
so he said do you know what i'm saying
but don't say that yeah
i'm not gonna say it i'm not saying it
but anyway he changed it to fubu the
rest is history and now we're watching
him on shark tank
and aren't you guys glad that you got
that little snippet
anyway but it just shows that's
marketing right there awareness
awareness awareness so he had fubu now
he's making a kill and he's on shark
tank he's doing his thing and he says
that he's he's got five
keys to success who is this this is this
is damon john the people shark
sharky up
holy [ __ ] asleep with the wheel damon
john
there he goes so i'm so incaptivated by
here well the buffoon but yeah fubu
is his uh
is his brand and he's got five keys to
success and he spells them out with like
an acronym
shark
s-h-a-r-k for our spelling inept people
out there and these are the five keys of
success according to the people shark
damon john number one s
for shark s
is to set a goal we talk about this all
the time number one with your finances
have a game plan for your money have a
budget have a business plan whatever it
is for the people shark is to set a goal
for him he wanted to make it in the
fashion world
with a little bit of hip hop vibe that
was his goal okay and he said
no excuses straight up this is what i'm
accomplishing i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
working on it i'm grinding he told
stories about selling clothes out of the
back of his trunk
working on the corner on the block going
up not being shy going up to ll cool j
begging him to do a commercial turns out
ll believed in him ll gave him a uh
allowed him to take a photo with him and
the rest was history i mean after years
and years of working on it but basically
the dude set a goal he worked on it and
then he just said watch them unfold
like marcelo you your goal
is to become
one of the biggest comedians in the
world and the biggest latin comedian in
the world is that not your goal at some
point probably a 10-year goal sure right
yeah like you're not doing this to be a
normal everyday comedian no no no you've
got a goal right and now you're watching
it unfold i remember i met you when you
were 19 you told me you were 21 at the
time yes you're 19. now you're 24. he
had a goal to become a big time comedian
now he's
literally touring the country with some
of the biggest comedians on the planet
he had a goal he worked on it now he's
watching it unfold right
this is true this is true more work to
be done more work to be done more work
to be done you know which speaking of
which what's the next one speaking of uh
the speaking of more work to be done the
h in shark is to do your homework right
basically he said listen
nothing's new
nothing is new it's all just updated and
he gave a list of things that nah you
know
you might think that this is new that's
just they did that back in the day and
just basically worked on all these
things that you think are new but
they're not okay
so he's saying do your research look at
data look at data
data or data a date yes data which one
data yes
i think data too uh and take inventory
of where you're at so do your homework
okay you think we just show up to this
podcast loosey goosey style and wing it
it's half homework half confidence 100
and we look at it you look at what your
performance you look at how you're doing
you look at how people are reacting the
give a [ __ ] level that's right it's real
that's right and no matter what business
you're in you can look at data right you
can look at core data quality data
yeah
you can find out get some feedback thank
you young men number three on the shark
if you're spelling s-h-a
i see what he did here is amore
for love oh he had to go to sleep you
see he went spanish though or italian
innovative
um he says you gotta love what you're
doing
if you don't love what you're doing you
could do it for a year you can do it for
two years a couple years at some point
you're saying i don't i just don't want
to be doing the [ __ ] level goes give a
[ __ ] level david
they give a [ __ ] level right thank you
for that also seinfeld has a legendary
quote about this he's um he says that
you can't do comedy for the money
because you'll get the money relatively
quickly
and then what is your motivation so like
the idea that let's say you're gonna try
to become a comedian and you know after
five years or five to eight years
you let's say you're paying your rent
with comedy you're touring this you're
doing this and that
now what is your
like what's your ambition to look for
more
if you're in it for the money and you're
already surviving then that's it then
you're kind of done yeah so it's like
you can't do it for the money you got to
do it because you love it you'll see
we're going to get to that in a second
so also
in addition to gotta love what you're
doing
it's the
who
do you love like what's your motivation
for him he told the story about his two
daughters he would do anything for them
neither of us have kids that i know of
but
at some point we're all gonna be fathers
we're gonna be husbands what have you
who are you doing this for right now
we're doing this for ourselves right
right so that's his thing i'm more love
what you're doing and who are you doing
it for r
remember
remember where you came from
remember that you are the brand
and to know yourself remember who you
are is basically what it is he's
basically saying we talked about an
elevator pitch in the last segment
be able to summarize your brand in two
to five words all we talk is money save
that money that's my brand
marcelo what's your brand
comedy two to five words
jokes me amigo
[Laughter]
i like that but work on that jokes
brother yeah right 100 work on that five
words or less david
uh
i don't haven't figured it out yet well
you work a brand so for everyone out
there that's working on a brand working
on your personal brand two to five words
this is what he says and this is
something interesting speaking of
knowing your brand know yourself knowing
who you want to be knowing what you want
to do he says when he gave a little
little peel behind the curtain of shark
tank he says
we don't invest in companies we invest
in people
the people business we're all in the
people business
okay so r remember who you are remember
what you stand for and remember you are
the brand marcelo
jokes
me amigo yes baby and and letter k for
our people following along
is to keep swimming this is a little
sentimental part of it
there's more life advice than business
advice he's saying look life is short
and it can be shorter than you even know
he says at one point he didn't he didn't
really this wasn't public knowledge he
had throat cancer and he showed uh he
showed a uh
he had uh something going on in his
throat let's just call it that and he
said he almost died of cancer
and um he's basically saying you got to
keep swimming and in order to do that
you got to take care of yourself don't
be sloppy okay right right get physicals
get some blood work done i know that all
too well it's not so much just what's
going on the outside get some blood work
done if you haven't had blood work done
get that done and then he says look
while you're keeping swimming you talked
about not doing it for the money what's
your purpose what's your motivation he
says like what does success really mean
to you and for him it wasn't the money
it wasn't being on shark tank it wasn't
buying businesses it wasn't social media
likes for him as we talked about earlier
it was his two daughters and family so
what's the point of all this shark right
set a goal
do your homework amore for love love
what you do remember who you are and you
are the brand and k
keep swimming playa and
at the end of this he says like what's
your
what's your why why are you doing this
so i always talk about
you know there's no you don't retire
anymore you're just what's called
chilling you own your time no matter you
could be 30 and chillin or you might be
80 and chillin but at the end of the day
know you're chillin know your why what's
your legacy a lot of people family
legacy they want to travel the world
they want to work on stuff they're
passionate about donate their time but
the big one is legacy and when we're
willing to lucky enough to have a family
one day
that'll take care of itself thoughts
on the people shark damon john
man a lot to take away from it uh
definitely puts things in perspective uh
the way he kind of breaks things down i
love that he used shark as an acronym
for it um yeah david john honestly at
the beginning of this i said mark i gave
two people yeah
he's not my favorite shark wow
yeah and i do agree that i like how he
did the amour thing because it could
have been
schlurk
but he said it doesn't matter
yeah yeah
shark amore love talk is money
all we talk is money if you enjoyed that
short clip from the sauce cast click
here to watch another click here to
watch the full episode or just stay
broken